In Turkey,
a moment of relief and joy,
as teams
hauled a three year old from the
So, you know, so
obviously
they're not
they're not sure they get it
in northern Syria.
A newborn girl was rescued
from the rubble of her home
and is now being treated in hosp
Relative says the baby's umbilic
was still attached to her mother
when she was found
and is believed to be the sole s
from her family
in another Syrian village.
This young girl comforted her si
while waiting for rescuers to fr
Her father tells CNN
the whole family survive
even though they'd be buried
beneath the rubble 4 hours
Aid agencies are particularly wo
about quake victims in Syria.
Nearly 70% of the population was
relying on humanitarian assistan
before this disaster.
Years of civil war, a very compl
search and rescue efforts
leading many to dig through the
with their bare hands.
More now from CNN's Salma Abdul
Ansari, a Canadian
of that
little rotted has lost her mothe
both her siblings, two,
all three killed by a massive ea
that leveled her home.
This was rather
just a few hours
before rush to safety
after she was pulled out of the
Her clothes stained with blood.
The toddler will be cared
for by her uncle
while her father recovers
in hospital from his wounds.
Activists say
this is a place all too familiar
with heartbreak
devastated by nearly 12 years of
There was little left to cope wi
another catalyst trophy
in northwestern
Syria was rattled
by a 7.8 magnitude
quake and dozens of aftershocks.
But in the first moments,
traumatize residents wondered
if warplanes were overhead again
Torn apart by civil conflict.
The response to this disaster is
along political lines
in the rebel held province of Id
Rescue workers known as the Whit
labored through the night to pul
out the dead and the living.
Drone shots
reveal the scope
and scale of their grim task.
While countless families
searching for missing loved ones
endure an agonizing wait.
But help can't reach everyone
in remote areas.
Relatives are desperately diggin
with bare hands.
I think
my family's underneath the rubbl
my children and grandchildren.
This man says.
But there's no way to get them o
No one to rescue them. No machin
I think they're still alive.
We hear their voices.
Catalina,
any survivors found are rushed
to overwhelmed hospitals like th
where beds for patients have run
The dead lay bleeding on the flo
and the body bags keep piling up
In government controlled areas.
Residents are largely cut off
from the international aid being
into the disaster zone.
President Bashar al-Assad's regi
is heavily sanctioned by the Wes
for bombarding his own people
here.
It's Syria supporters.
The patrons of the conflict.
Russia in Iran are offering aid.
Moscow's troops are supporting
search and recovery efforts.
And President Putin
has vowed to send more help
but disaster knows no politics h
Families are desperate for news
top it, Teddy.
Well, you can I can't find my si
This woman says
she lived on the second floor
with her son and three daughters
Maybe they didn't get out.
We've checked the hospitals.
We've looked everywhere for them
God, I hope they're okay.
Syrians
feel their plight was long
forgotten and neglected.
Now, with their tragedy
thrust into the spotlight, again
it's up to the world to hear the
Sam Abdul Aziz, CNN, Istanbul.